aujourd'hui ils ceux qui ont la clé
vraiment de peut-être pour éviter un
confinement
ce sont les plus jeunes se sont comme
voilà vous avez pris l'exemple de cet
anniversaire d anniversaire arrive en
avoir des milliers ce week-end et bien
des anniversaires à 70 personnes dans un
appart ou dans une maison il faut les
annuler voilà vous fera l'anniversaire
plus tard les anniversaires c'est tous
les ans ou alors on fera l'année
prochaine par définition non mais c'est
voilà c'est ça c'est ce qu'il faut faire
passer comme message c'est vraiment
qu'aujourd'hui c'est par les jeunes par
les fêtes par les rassemblements qu'on
fait qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir du mal à
juguler
voilà l à la contamination et c'est ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure le virus
de la fête mois cette expression je
pense qu'il va rester aussi de cette
soirée et c'est vous qui l'avez n'y est
jeune et c'est vrai que ça on l'avait
jamais entendu message marque est
déposée et je pense que ça voilà tous
ceux qui nous regardent ce soir
le virus de la fête pensez-y à chaque
moment s'arrête le week-end là qui va
arriver dès demain voilà respecter les
gestes barrière mettez vos masques et
c'est vrai que ça a été vraiment ça ça
va rester le virus doit fait oui oui
j'ai julie et dit ce qu'ils voulaient cn
c'est très important de le dire de cette
manière là gabriel il faut vraiment à
l'époque a brillé alors ça y est vous c
vont troquer jamais non mais c'est très
important de le dire de cette manière et
mais il faut aller aussi plus loin parce
que ceux qui n'ont pas regardé cette
émission ne savent pas vraiment et on a
un petit peu perdues les jeunes
danseuses dans ce combat on se sent
notre génération de jeunes un peu un
20,6 par rapport à ce virus soit on l'a
attrapé et on pense qu'on peut plus le
rattraper donc je sais peut-être une
question qu'on va vous poser après
monsieur le médecin de est ce qu'on peut
leur ai attrapé parce qu'il ya toute une
légende urbaine autour du de la récidive
du virus et il faut vraiment je sais pas
peut-être en parler dans les écoles ou
dans les lycées dans les facs matraque
et j'suis pas des voitures chez les
choses rhodia ou et vous réunir parce
que on est invité tous les soirs à des à
des soirées quoi c'est vrai que sur les
personnages comme la communication a les
clés pourquoi vous êtes là tous pourquoi
est-ce que cyril vous a invité parce que
vous avez tous des communautés vous êtes
suivi par d'autres jeunes vous êtes des
exemples pour d'autres jeunes
je pense qu'il y en a d'autres qui nous
regardent qui au csu avait des relais et
donc on a besoin de vous pour passer ses
messages sur vos réseaux sociaux
on essaye aussi
ornements d'être innovant mois tous les
jeudis sur mon compte instagram je fais
une session de questions réponses avec
les personnes qui me suivent qui me
posent des questions en plus c'est par
message donc on n'a pas forcément n'a
pas honte de poser une question dont on
dit qu'elle est peut-être jet et
j'essaye de répondre aux plus de
questions possibles on essaye de
développer ça mais on a besoin aussi que
des jeunes qui parlent à d'autres jeunes
s'en fassent les relais est passé ses
messages et justement pourquoi vous
n'avez pas inviter les 50m flux
annonceurs phrase c'est toutes les
semaines de que pour leur dire voilà on
a besoin de vous faites un message non
mais je parle du gouvernement et je
parle je te pose le gouvernement met
donc avec le premier ministre qu'il n'y
a pas de problème non mais pourquoi
voulez pas fait c'est une idée ça mais
ça y est le faire un porte-parole a très
bien au rendez vous et vous mettrez à
aller faire venir parce que ils sont là
bas je sais bien mais si vous voulez si
vous voulez mon fait semaine une réunion
en parallèle de la conférence de presse
classique qui est fait partie de la
vérité en face une réunion porte parolat
du gouvernement avec les influenceurs %
pour relayer les messages à répondre aux
questions que vous êtes un grand coup on
organise à partir à partir la semaine
prochaine mais c'est rien mais les
anniversaires maintenant peut être des
réunions avec le masque sur la
communication
j'ai un autre souci mais qui peut
forcément se régler jusqu'à moi
personnellement nous on a 26 ans on a
une entreprise on la fin à cette crise
je trouve que elle est bien gérée par
l'état français financièrement cirque on
s'est pas senti dans la merde on se sent
soutenu je me sens évidemment on a plein
de potes qui sont en danger plein
d'entreprises qui ferment leurs portes
pour vous mais y en a plein qui sont des
biens sur lui quand on regarde la
situation par rapport à des potes à nous
qui habitent aux états unis qui sont
limite à turin dans l'aude a été très
mal gérée voilà on se dit que ça va
rassurer
par contre et c'est le ressenti de
beaucoup de mes abonnés et de beaucoup
de gens parfois j'ai l'impression que
vous mitraillé mitraillé mitraille
locaux vides aux infos et demi de vous
délaissez certains sujets en fait je
pense que là on est à l'aube d'un une
nouvelle époque d'un nouveau jour c'est
l'occasion pour nous de créer un nouveau
monde
un truc trop stylé où on est plus tous
un peu des connards voilà donc est-ce
que vous avez pas envie d'adresser
certains sujets puisque on a vécu quand
même des trucs de ouf dans le monde ces
derniers temps je pense notamment à
blake lively matters chance aux
violences faites aux femmes
je pense aux à l'impact écologique le
ménage au phénomène climatique aussi qui
se passe
ils sont joueurs tous les week
personnellement moi j'ai 26 ans je
consomme pas bfmtv je ne vous ai jamais
entendu parler des ouigours qui est en
fait un phénomène terrible d'internement
dans des camps de concentration de
musulmans en chine
oui on en a parlé donc un pacte
écologique violences faites aux femmes
blacklight matters enfin c'est un
mouvement qui est mondial personne n'en
parle vraiment à part pour parler de
séparatisme je trouve ça trop dommage
mais est-ce qu'on va pas construire un
nouveau monde comme si au niveau de la
com de vous répondre
un nouveau monde hyper cool sur ces
sujets là julien lui à moi je moi je me
suis dit oui parce que je lui dis
laissez moi c'est pas pour moi c'est
julien ellis s'est sentie inquiète son
élément et non mais moi je vais vous
dire vous parlez de vous parler un peu
d'aidé des chaînes d'information parler
des grandes messes
voilà du 20h pouvoir sur tf1 sur france
2 c'est pas le gouvernement qui ne s'y
cacher il faut récupérer les gens non
non ça se passait comme ça il ya
quelques années sur mais là ça s'est
quand même gouvernement d'aller chercher
en 3g ou dire ils vont venir vous
chercher
mais c'est très simple il faut que vous
sachiez un truc au journalisme ce qui
intéresse c'est ce qui se passe en
france
donc les journaux télévisés et penser à
une chose exaucé fait c'est faire de
l'audience
les ouigours c'est un drame ce qui se
passe actuellement en chine
j'en ai parlé encore aujourd'hui sur mon
instinct j'ai vu qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se sont mobilisés également
beaucoup de beaucoup d'artistes ça on
n'en parle pas parce que je vous dis ça
mal au monde a manqué à activer en
france quand on achète une paire de
baskets non mais bien sûr nous sommes
énormes et l'impact des esclaves est
normal qu'ils n'ont pas vu l'italie
cherche à une colline que je vous dis le
problème qu'on a bien sûr aujourd'hui
c'est que les rédactions et c'est leur
droit et elle fonce à elles sont sur le
sanctionner le sensationnalisme elles
veulent faire peur elles disent qu est
ce qui intéresse les gens aujourd'hui
c'est le co vide c'est faire peur c'est
à dire qui a reconquis mot dire qu'on
risque voilà qui est plus en plus de cas
les ouigours oui c'est un drame ce qui
se passe là-bas mais malheureusement on
n'en parle pas assez sur les chaînes
d'info et sur les grandes chaînes sur
les grands médias
voilà vous avez parlé de votre mouvement
le problème c'est que ça se passera en
france aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce qui
intéresse les français et il pense
d'abord à leurs audiences us ou 10 6 10
bannu oui mais moi je parle des années
durant ces jeux
pas de des gens qui consomment bfm
franchement je n'ai même pas télé chez
moi je parle des jeunes ouais on a juste
besoin d'un petit je vous ai compris
parce que sur les sujets qui nous font
en ce moment je sais pas si vous êtes
d'accord
sailly en fait nous on a compris le coc
vide je suis prête à faire des efforts
je suis prête à ne plus aller en teuf
j'aimerais juste que bon déjà il ya un
peu plus de pédagogie sur ce sujet qu'on
nous explique clairement les choses en
mode limite si vous pouvez nous dire
typiquement une journée de citoyens
jeunes exemplaire c'est quoi j'aimerais
bien bassaget très bien mais je pense
qu'il ya aussi un enjeu qui est social
et sociétal si vous voulez pas que
demain les jeunes en fait il ne vous
écoutent plus et qu'ils votent pour des
extrêmes bas qui eux vont aller les
récupérer et dia et nous on vous écoute
sur ces sujets là parce que ce que c'est
eux qui vont moins écologique des masses
franchement en 2020 qu' il ya des
masques partout ne serait-ce que chez
moi y'a genre 50 masques éparpillés
partout je sais même pas dans quelques
jours et le jeter c'est du plastique
enfin c'est une espèce de polystyrène
qui plairont pue de la gueule avec ce
truc mais voilà j'ai bien votre
témoignage là sur sa merci un scène
tient beaucoup à coeur non mais je pense
que vraiment il faut pas oublier que ces
sujets qui vous intéressent aujourd'hui
alors débarrassé les violences
policières c'est le sujet du racisme
je sais que c'est incomparable existence
aux états unis et que j'ai pas du tout
envie d'entrer dans ce sujet voilà un
autre je voulais revenir me sujet la
question des violences faites aux femmes
pendant confinement les violences faites
aux femmes ont augmenté de 30%
qu'est ce qui est fait aujourd'hui
concret valérie gsm les violences aussi
sur cher aussi les enfants et je sais
que vous faites des choses mais je pense
que vous les communiquer au mauvais
endroit parce que je sais que castex il
a fait un post par exemple récemment
repris à ses ex premier ministre
il a fait un poste récemment pour dire
qu' il était allé donner de l'argent à
la maison des femmes qui est une maison
qui est des familles sur les violences
dans le 93
franchement j'en ai jamais entendu
parler moi enfin vous ne vous attaquez
pas à nos canaux en fait donc on
n'entend pas parler d'autres qui sont
sûrement cool
le plan de relance je comprenais rien
j'ai regardé vite fait j'ai trouvé ça
trop cool et je me suis dit pourquoi je
suis pas au courant que finalement
l'état c'est pas si nul ce qu'ils font
pourquoi vous en parlez pas pourquoi
vous venez pas nous chercher nous dire
les gars on est là pour vous je sais que
ça va pas franchement est ce soir
d'ailleurs 90 en direct sur twitter
royal parle à mes deux bouquins aussi
voilà et on essaie au doigt par la
maintenance quelques vides mais prenez
nous par bompard à l'américain